UKRAINE IS GETTING PUMMELED BY ANOTHER
WAVE OF RUSSIAN AIRSTRIKES.
TARGETING ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
ARID SILENCE RUN OUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TODAY IN WHAT KYIV IS
CALLING ONE OF THE BIGGEST
MISSILE ATTACKS SINCE THE START
OF THE WAR.
PIERRE THE SOUTHERN REGION ALL
HITS THE DESCRIBED IMAGE THERE,
AS COLOSSAL.
THERE'S NO ELECTRICITY, HEAT,
OR WATER.
UKRAINE SAYS 76 MISSILES HAVE
ALREADY BEEN LAUNCHED, AND
THEREFORE SPOKESMAN SAYS FOR
THE FIRST TIME, RUSSIA HAS USED
STRATEGIC BOMBERS.
UKRAINE'S STATE ENERGY PROVIDES
MORE URGENCY MODE ACTIVATED,
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
TARGETED.
CNN'S RIPLEY HAS MORE NOW FROM
KYIV.
>> THE KYIV CIVIL MILITARY
ADMINISTRATION SAYS THE
UKRAINIAN CAPITAL HAS SURVIVED.
ONE OF THE MOST MASSIVE MISSILE
ATTACKS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE FULL SCALE INVASION.
YOU CAN SEE DESTROYED VEHICLES
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE WAR.
WE ACTUALLY CAN'T TAKE YOU TO
THE SCENE OF THESE ATTACKS
BECAUSE OF THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE, THEY HAVE ROADS
ABOUT FILMING AND SHOWING THOSE
OCCASIONS, THEY DON'T WANT IT
TO WHAT THE RUSSIANS TO WHAT
AREAS THEY MIGHT HAVE HIT AND
OR MISSED.
MOST OF THE MISSILES NUMBER
WHICH THEIR TARGETS BECAUSE OUT
OF ABOUT 40 MISSILES THEY IT,
THROUGHOUT THE FULL SCALE WAR
FOR NEARLY TEN MONTHS NOW, THEY
SHOT DOWN 37 OF THEM.
THERE WERE THREE EXPLOSIONS
REPORTED HERE IN KYIV, ON THE
EAST AND WEST BANKS OF THE
RIVER, TO END THE, EAST ONE IN
THE WEST.
AND THERE WERE REPORTS ACROSS
UKRAINE OF ENTIRE CITIES
PLUNGING INTO DARKNESS, AS A
RESULT OF THESE ATTACKS.
WHICH DIDN'T JUST HIT HERE IN
KYIV IT HIT HERE IN SOUTH ODESA.
AND KHARKIV.
HERE IN THE CAPITAL, THERE WERE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
SHELTERING IN PLACE, HIDING
UNDERGROUND SUBWAY STATIONS,
WAITING FOR AN ALL-CLEAR.
AND THERE WERE SOUNDS OF
EXPLOSIONS.
WE HEARD THEM THIS MORNING AS
WE WERE GETTING READY TO PACK
UP AND GO TO ROAD TRIP.
THERE WERE LOUD EXPLOSIONS
HEARD IN OUR VICINITY.
CNN STAFF A LIVE DEVIN CLOSER
TO THIS PART OF THE EXPLOSIONS
THAT THEY HEARD THE SOUND OF
THE AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM,
ACTIVATED, SHOOTING DOWN,
DOZENS OF MISSILES HEADED
TOWARDS THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
THE NUMBER OF DEAD AND INJURED
--
THOSE REPORTS ARE ALWAYS FLUID
BUT AS OF RIGHT NOW WE KNOW TO
BE ABLE KILLED.
FIVE PEOPLE WERE INJURED,
INCLUDING CHILDREN, AND UNICEF
WARNED THESE ONGOING ATTACKS,
AND BOMBARDMENT OF THE CIVILIAN
POWER INFRASTRUCTURE PUTS THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH OF
NEARLY EVERY CHILD OF UKRAINE
AT DESPERATE RISK.
WILL RIPLEY, CNN, KYIV,
UKRAINE.
>> THANKS TO --
PATRIOT MISSILES TO UKRAINE
EXPECTED AT ANYTIME AND IT
BECOMES A MYTH THESE CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURES.
THE PENTAGON SAYS THE KREMLIN
DOES NOT HAVE A SAY IN THE
MATTER AND WILL NOT DICTATE
WHAT THE SECURITY PROVIDED TO
UKRAINE.
>> I FIND IT IRONIC AND VERY
TELLING THAT OFFICIALS FROM A
COUNTRY THAT BRUTALLY ATTACKED
ITS NEIGHBOR IN AN ILLEGAL AND
UNPROVOKED INVASION THROUGH A
CAMPAIGN THAT IS DELIBERATELY
TARGETING AND KILLING INNOCENT
CIVILIANS, AND DESTROYING
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
THEY WOULD CHOOSE TO USE WORDS
LIKE PROVOCATIVE TO DESCRIBE
DEFENSIVE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
MEANT TO SAVE LIVES AND PROTECT
CIVILIANS.
>> RUSSIA ONES OF UNPREDICTABLE
CONSEQUENCES IF RUSSIA DEPLOYS
THE DEFENSE SYSTEM TO UKRAINE.
IN WHAT IS BEING DESCRIBED AS
ANOTHER PROVOCATIVE MOVE BY THE
UNITED STATES.
JOINING ME LIVE AT THE PENTAGON,
UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN ASKING AND
REQUESTING WELCOME NEWS.
AS WE UNDERSTAND, THEY REQUIRE
INTENSIVE TRAINING TO OPERATE,
SO HOW SOON OF THINK COULD THEY
BE AN OPERATION?
>> NO ONE REALLY IS TALKING
ABOUT THAT AT THIS POINT.
STILL PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
SIGNATURE ON THE DOTTED LINE,
IF YOU WILL, NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
THE FINAL APPROVAL TO SHIP
PATRIOT MISSILES SYSTEMS TO
UKRAINE.
IT WILL TAKE SOME PERIOD OF
TIME TO GET THEM THERE, AND
THEN ONCE THAT THERE, UKRAINIAN
TROOPS MOST LIKELY HAVE TO GO
TO GERMANY TO BE TRAINED ON THE
SYSTEMS.
AND, IT'S NOT JUST THE TRAINING,
IT IS THE REPAIR AT THE, SPARE,
PARTS THE MAINTENANCE.
SO, IT'S A COMPLEX SYSTEM BUT
THE U.S. AND UKRAINE APPEAR TO
HAVE COME TO AN AGREEMENT THAT
IT IS REALLY WORTH IT TO GET
THIS DONE IN THE FACE OF THIS
RUSSIAN MISSILE BARRAGES.
THE ADVANTAGES OF PATRIOT'S ITS
RADAR CAN LOCK ON TO AN
INCOMING BALLISTIC MISSILE AND
SHOOT IT DOWN AT SOME ALTITUDE
AND DISTANCE FROM ITS TARGET
INSIDE UKRAINE.
SO, THAT WILL BE A HUGE
BENEFIT.
ESPECIALLY AS WINTER APPROACHES,
AND THEY'RE TRYING HARD TO KEEP
THE POWER SYSTEMS RUNNING FOR
THE PEOPLE THERE.
AT THE SAME TIME, THE U.S. IS
ANNOUNCING ITS INCREASING ITS
OVERALL TRAINING OF UKRAINIAN
FORCES, NOW, IT'S GOING TO BE
ABOUT 500 TROOPS A MONTH, IN
GERMANY.
AND AT A TRAINING AREA THAT THE
U.S. OPERATES IN GERMANY, THEY
ARE GOING TO ACCELERATE,
ESCALATE THE TRAINING IF YOU
WILL, GET THEM BETTER TRAINED
ON MORE COMPLEX SYSTEMS, AND
ITS UNITS, YOU KNOW, BASICALLY
MOVING BEYOND THE INDIVIDUALS.
UKRAINE TOLD ARE NOW, GETTING
THESE UNITS FULLY CAPABLE AND
TRAINED OF BEING ABLE TO
OPERATE ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
CHRISTINA?
>> THE PENTAGON FOR, US THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.